à écouter roman polanski est un
pédocriminels qui a drogué ce dôme ise
et violé une jeune femme de 13 ans j'ai
besoin d'en dire plus ça suffit pas à
partir de ce moment là excusez moi
pourquoi est-ce qu'on doit se justifier
quand on parle de dollars 1 karim a pris
le bel exemple les ouvriers mais un
prêtre pédophile est ce qu'on va dire
mais je fais des bonnes metz mais il a
touché leur guide et alors ça il y en a
quand même beaucoup en liberté
aujourd'hui il y en a il faut arrêter de
vouloir séparer l'homme de l'artiste
c'est un concept des hommes puissants
pour les hommes puissants à boulanger
qui viole un enfant lui dirai rien si
qu'est-ce qu'il fait des bonnes blagues
sais pas si les gens iraient d'alors de
l'art et ce dès demain le messin est
géré par jour mais je dirais pas bah
c'est ce qu'a dit le régime estime ilian
aux gens c'est si vous êtes un cinéaste
de renommée
vous pouvez violer en toute impunité les
gens désormais n'oubliez pas que pour
être et bauer avec tout le respect que
j'ai pour les éboueurs il faut un casier
judiciaire vierge
mais le mec qui violent des gens et là
droit d'avoir une tribune mais sans
problème et on va le payer et il va voir
u2 se faire petit comme vous le dites il
pourrait se dire c'est ça j'ai déconné
bah oui bon j'étais assez d'argent
franchement et là où c'est hypocrite ou
bien il peut il peut mettre quelqu'un
d'autre à la presse il a vraiment envie
de faire ce film
il ne fait pas lui le signe pas lui et
moi je vous dire un truc ce qu'il a dit
est ce que j'espère c'est une question
posée 2 voilà est-ce que vous en voulez
à ceux qui ont financé son film parce
que mine de rien il est peut pas le
faire tout seul le fuit la région île de
france par exemple
non mais voilà est-ce que vous voulez à
ceux qui ont financé envie de moi la
vraie question pour moi aussi elle est
là parce que le gars si oui c'est un
taré il a il est condamné aux états unis
il fait le beau en france il veut faire
absolument son film mais qui est dédié
gens pour le soutenir et des gens pour
soutenir son film et pour mettre de
l'argent dans son film moi mais la série
est ce que tu rends il ferait d'innover
c utilise très importante parce que
plutôt que de pointer et de blâmer le
citoyen c'est ça qui il va avoir une
oeuvre collective et cinématographique
qui aurait plutôt que ça c'est sa pointe
aux institutions judiciaires qui ne
l'extra de bain et de nos collectivités
sinon collectivités territoriales la
rivière huaihe avec madame pécresse qui
est à sa tête de queue et et qui prétend
effectuant mener un combat de que pau
pour l'afa merde je veux bien la croire
mais à mon nez ça se démontre aussi bien
les arcanes politiques parce que c'est
aux financer les actions manquées lequel
les arrivées d'eau criminels veut dire
quelque part on aime nous conduisent
aussi à rim
est-ce que tu étais au courant des actes
de polanski avant est ce que tu les as
de nom
c est ce que quelqu'un a dénoncé quoi
que ce soit la météo le savez les
semaines non mais est ce que quelqu'un a
dit le fils me laisse pas fait en deux
jours oui quelqu'un il ya deux semaines
trois semaines un mois non c'est pas
juste alors ans après je vous laisse pas
désolé quelqu'un qui a voulu au lit une
fille mais m'bia quarante trois ans et
qui veut fermer ce niveau plus vu en
france je n'ai pas de dose et sur lui
mais jamais donné les choses et j'espère
le problème il est triple à la justice
on ne comprend pas on va expliquer
pourquoi ce soir effectivement avec tout
ce qu'il a fait il n'est pas en prison
ça on est d'accord
2 les gens qui financent effectivement
maintenant le film il est fait il est
financé il ya plus de trente cinq
acteurs c'est une oeuvre c'est pas
l'oeuvre seulement de polanski c'est un
film qui existent avec des gens qu'on
travaillait et à donner mais laissez moi
finir mais vous pouvez appeler au
boycott mais vous lui faites de la pub
c'est pour nous aussi c'est pour ça moi
je m'en fous explosé lecture aux jeunes
madame pécresse est en effet question de
m même si c'est une amie tu regrettes ou
pas mais non mais non mais c'est quoi
cette attaque je ne sais pas moi je pose
une question c'est quoi cette question
alors j'ai fini je m'arrête deux
secondes tout ce que vous voulez dire
qu'est ce que tu as fait dans ta vie
pour empêcher romane polanski de faire
voici lé palais propose à laval on
dirait qu on atterrit ont dit non on a
bien roulé passe justement on dirait que
vous atterrissez aussi mais il fallait
milices et de montrer ses lunettes la
région ile de france
avant on a collectivité fait quand même
revenir je voudrais quand même revenir à
la base c'était nous les expliquer
pourquoi j'ai dit non j'ai dit non parce
que je pense que ça dessert la cause et
que ça sert sa cause à lui sa serre sont
faits et deuxième chose si c'était un
homme sur scène comme bertrand cantat
par exemple avec seulement l'oeuvre et
l'homme sur la scène effectivement là
c'est insupportable je peux mais là
c'est une oeuvre collective